- Speaking of friendship and football
let's get to today's
starting lineup, shall we?
They're four of the most
celebrated actresses in history.
They're icons.
But they're also really,
really good friends.
(upbeat music)
So, playing out of Puerto
Rico by way of Broadway,
she was one of the first
to EGOT up with two Emmys,
two Grammys, an Oscar, and a Tony,
as well as a Presidential
Medal of Freedom.
We've got Rita Moreno!
(audience cheering)
Rita Moreno, y'all.
A local from Birmingham
High School in the valley
where she was a cheerleader.
Her record stands at
three Emmys, two Oscars,
a Kennedy Center Honors,
and fresh off of a SAG
lifetime achievement award.
It's Sally Field!
(audience cheering)
On offense, we've got a Motor City native
who played briefly at
Wayne State University
before she went on to earn seven Emmys,
two Tonys, a Grammy and a
Mark Twain prize for comedy.
Miss Lily Tomlin!
(audience cheering)
And rounding out the field people,
from New York City and Vassar College,
with has seven Golden Globes, two Oscars.
Cecil B. Demille Award, and six arrests
for all the right reasons.
It's the one and only, Jane Fonda.
(audience cheering)
Together they star in the
new movie that I love,
it's called "80 for Brady."
It's in theaters starting February 3rd.
Give it up for an
Allstar team, Jane Fonda,
Lilly Tomlin, Sally
Field, and Rita Moreno!
(audience cheering)
(upbeat groovy music)
- All ladies.
- I know.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly laughing)
It is...
They're not stopping.
- That guy right there is egging them on,
he's egging them on.
- They are incredible, I get it.
No, they, it is an incredible thing
to have four powerhouses
come out in this industry,
all at once especially outta a helmet.
That's incredible.
No, are y'all all football
fans in real life?
- Yes.
- Me too.
- [Speaker] Oh yeah.
- Are you? You answered quickly.
You have yet to say anything.
- I'm a baseball.
- [Kelly] Oh, okay.
- [Sally] I'm baseball too.
- You're baseball too, you like sport.
You're my friend, my friends
love any kind of sport.
- She's got three sons.
- Oh, you were destined, yeah, yeah.
- That's right I have three sons,
but I'm all on my own into baseball.
That was a new obsession.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Obsession, totally
freaked out obsession.
I think I watched every
single Dodger game last year,
(audience cheering)
and then they have like 4,000 every year.
I mean, there's so many games.
- Let's go to a game together.
- Oh yes.
- I went to Texas Ranger games.
I grew up in Texas, but
I went for the hot dogs
and the food, yeah,
that's what I went for.
- Kansas City has the best hot dogs.
- Oh my God, they have
great food in general.
- Who?
- Barbecue.
- Kansas City.
- They have best dogs?
- [Jane] Baseball food, yeah, hot dogs.
- Also, great initials, KC.
(people laughing)
It's the only other like
sport thing I'll wear
'cause it's great initials.
So you're all icons, but
you've never worked together,
like all together, have you?
- Well, we've done a few things together.
- Yes, yeah, a couple, but
I just mean all together.
(audience cheering)
But this is the first time
you've all worked together,
right?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I met Jane
when she was producing
the TV version of 9 to 5,
and I was playing Violet
Newstead in the TV show.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
- Yeah, that was long time ago.
- That's incredibly cool to
have that kind of friendship
in an industry that can be hard
on women and hard for women.
- [Rita] Yeah.
- That's cool.
- I don't call Jane for that.
(people laughing)
Just sex instructions.
- You know what...
So jealous of you right now.
- [Lily] Dedicated to you.
- She said, "No, no, we don't."
(people laughing)
Wait, what was it like to
finally do that though?
Work together?
Like being and (indistinct) together.
Did you get, I imagine like
even if I work on "The Voice,"
it's like friends, we're
all friends, right?
It's hard to get anything done.
- What, right from the very
first time we got together,
we started talking and
we wouldn't stop talking.
We had so many things to share...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And the director,
he couldn't get us to
leave what we were doing
and go to the set and do our jobs.
I mean, it was a problem.
- I mean sometimes they would
be saying, "Okay everybody,
rolling," and we'd
still be chattering away
and we couldn't even give
him a chance to say action.
(people laughing)
- That must have been fun for him.
- [Jane] It was.
- So, I heard that you
all compared surgeries
at one point, which is hysterical.
- That's my story
because I was the one who could
notice what we were doing,
the very first day of rehearsal,
first day, before we
were shooting anything,
we were rehearsing to learn a dance
that we have to do in the movie.
- Which is incredible.
- [Rita] Thank you.
- That's one of it's my favorite parts.
- Anyway, before you knew it,
I don't even know how it started,
we started talking about our surgeries.
- Well, that was because
it some, you know,
sometimes it was Jane had just
had her shoulder replacement.
It was a little hard to do
some of the moves, so...
- [Rita] And you had shoulder replacement.
- Well, that but way further
back, but still, we didn't...
- Before you know it,
everybody's talking about
operations and surgery.
- Well.
(Kelly laughing)
- This is the first, literally
the first hour of rehearsal.
- [Lily] That's what
happens when you're old,
that's what you do.
- That's right, that's right, comparing.
- Well, we could have talked
about childbirth, but you know.
- No one wants to remember that.
- Jane won the all of the steel ones.
- You won?
- Yeah, I only have one
joint left that's mine.
I'm not kidding.
(Kelly laughing)
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
- [Rita] She's not kidding.
- And that she's gonna
smoke later on today.
(people laughing)
- Come on.
(audience cheering)
- So Lily, will you explain
what the movie is about?
You play a pretty pivotal role,
I had no idea what it was about,
by the way going in, like the depth of it.
And I had no idea the truth behind it
with what actually happens
in Tom Brady's life
and the real women that
it was inspired by.
- Right, it's based on a story
about five women actually,
that but one had gone already,
but the four women that are left,
the story was based on the
true experience they had
because they were devoted
devout fans of Tom Brady
and football and they'd been watching him
every Sunday for 10 years,
and then they decide to
go to bite the bullet
and go to Houston for
the Super Bowl in 2017,
which was that incredible
game that they played.
- Yeah, I knew it was gonna be fun
and I know it was gonna be funny,
but there's so much heart to it.
And even how you get into football,
even how that happens with your character
and how you all pull
through for that character.
I think we all have friends
like that in our life.
Those are our people we call.
- Right.
- It's so relatable, but Lily,
you shared a big scene with Tom Brady,
like I thought he did
really well as an actor?
- Oh yes, he's very good, very natural.
- I hate sounding
shocked, but I was, yeah.
You know, I just, we don't, like, you know
I've made from Justin to Kelly,
not all of us are actors.
I'm just saying like,
you know what I'm saying?
We're not all there.
And so it was impressive.
I thought he did really, really well.
- No, I was really quite impressed too.
And I was happy and
pleased, it was so natural,
and he was such...
(audience cheering)
Oh, there.
- Jane and Lily have a scene
and they're in bed together.
That's it, that's just
what I wanted to say.
No, (indistinct) how did that go?
Because you were, you were spooning.
- We...
(audience laughing)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
There was no space for the Lord.
(people laughing)
- She initiated the spoon.
- [Kelly] All right.
- Well, you know, I figured
me and her character
have known each other all our lives,
we went to elementary school together,
and we've had sleepovers
when we were younger.
And I always spooned her so why not?
Just because, just because
we're in our eighties
and she felt so good.
(people laughing)
- [Kelly] Just felt right.
- And we were just, we were loaded anyway,
at that moment, all four of us were.
- Oh my god, that part, look at her eyes,
she was like, "I'm not saying anything."
So you mentioned you all shared
dance scene in the movie.
Let's see, it let's everybody watch this.
I love this is how you got in.
(gentle upbeat music)
- Little freak down here.
Oh.
- [Kelly] Oh, there it is.
- 5, 6, 7, 8.
- [Kelly] Look at Lily in the
back, she's like get down.
- [Speaker] Yeah.
(Kelly laughing)
- Rita, you're killing me.
(audience cheering)
I just love, when I was watching it,
I was like did you request
to be in the very back?
Like all of a sudden I see red pants
and you're just like
getting down back there.
- I think maybe they may have requested
that I get in the back.
- Did you enjoy the dance
or was this when the conversation
about surgeries came up?
(Lily laughing)
Was this like, was it fun?
- Was in the rehearsal,
when some of 'em came up
with that about, "Oh, I can't do that one
and we can't turn that way and that..."
- I can't lift my arm up this way.
- Yeah.
- And so that's, okay that move is out.
(audience laughing)
- Oh my God, so it started bigger
and they were just like,
"Nope, nope, nope."
- It got smaller and smaller and shorter.
- Touch step, yeah, or
step touch I mean yeah.
- It was a 10 minute
dance, it isn't anymore.
(people laughing)
- Oh my God.
You were hilarious in
it, just sassy as hell.
I loved it.
- Well, you know
the hard part of something
like that is to dance not well.
- Yeah, if you're a dancer.
- I mean when you know how to dance.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And then you have to kind of pretend
that you don't know how to do that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But the thing...
- You did that very, very well then.
(people laughing)
- No, that's true.
We always make jokes, but Jessi,
the singer that works with me on the show,
she's so good at singing off
key and being funny about it
and it is hard to do.
- [Rita] Yeah.
- When you're so trained to not,
you're trained to be on key.
- Exactly.
- That is very hard to do but
I thought you looked elegant,
I liked it.